well we know that there was a a cobra
meeting at officials level and that is
the the government's crisis meeting
grouping a real sign that that this is a
serious crisis for the UK government and
usually when you have an officials level
meeting that will usually be followed by
a minister's level meeting this is
probably the last thing that Teresa may
would have wanted to have happened at
the very end of her watch but it really
is a crisis it's the the kind of worst
nightmare scenario that we had ever
since Iran threatened to target British
tankers following the seizure with the
help of British Royal Marines of an
Iranian tanker off the coast of
Gibraltar two weeks ago since then we've
had evidence of the Royal Navy a warship
hms hms Montrose a type 23 frigate not
it not officially escorting but for all
intents and purposes escorting a number
of commercial ships through the Strait
of Hormuz that narrow waterway between
Iran and the United Arab Arab Emirates
and on this occasion though there was no
Royal Navy ship it would seem able to
intervene to prevent what looks like a
military operation to force this British
flag tanker to turn swiftly into Iranian
waters and now be held by the Iranians
it's a significant escalation and one
that will go that goes against what
Britain has been trying to achieve
throughout the heightened tensions
between the United States and Iran in
the Gulf and that is for de-escalation
so it really will remain to be seen how
the UK does respond
obviously the priority is to secure the
release of this tanker and this the safe
release of its 23 crew members Iran will
most likely be wanting in return the
release of its tanker Britain has tried
the whole way through since the seizure
of the grace one tanker off tube rota
to differentiate between that situation
which it says was all about upholding EU
sanctions against importing oil into
Syria and the crisis in the Gulf Iran
sees no such distinction
it wants the release of its tanker and
you could well imagine it holding this
British tanker until that happens
Deborah there's been some criticism this
evening that the British Navy simply
hasn't been doing enough to escort
British flagged vessels through the
Strait of Hormuz at this very sensitive
and difficult time just remind us of
what Navy hardware is current in the
region yes that criticism is is to be
expected frankly it's not like Britain
didn't have sufficient warning that its
vessels were specifically being targeted
by Iran however for the UK side of
things they've got to tread this
delicate balancing act between not
wanting to escalate the situation by
increasing their military presence
significantly in the Gulf